[Music]
Hello and welcome to I'd like to know.
My name is CA Murray and as you can
readily see we have grown and we are
very very happy about that. Uh our usual
cohort pastor Boris here and pastor good
to see you as always. Same here CA and
and uh the new kid on the block is
Pastor Daniel Miranda. He is uh the
newest employee he and his lovely wife
and uh he has been on this program once
before and did such a fine job. You see,
the worst thing you can do at Secret
Sale is do something well. Okay. And
since you did it well, you get it
full-time now. Yeah. Amen. So, we praise
the Lord to have Pastor Morant his
student of the word, a fine preacher,
good-looking young man, and we are
looking for And of course, he is
bilingual. And I guess everybody here is
bilingual except me. You are. You are
too. You're dangerously bilingual.
I do understand a little bit more than I
speak, but it it's fun being here.
Because we all love studying the word
and that's why we love this program so
much because it gives us a chance to
listen to your questions to respond to
your questions and as usual we make you
this promise. If it can be found in the
word of God we will find it in the word
of God and every answer we give you will
be from the word of God. As late as we
are dear pastors in this earth's history
we don't need the mindset of men. We
need the word from the Lord. And that's
what we promise to give you. We'll take
as much time as we can as we need to
with your questions, but we want you to
send them in because we like
investigation and we like going into the
word of God. Should you want to send in
a question, you can do so by sending
your question to tvsumtv.org.
That is tvsumtv.orgg
and uh we will get to them. The stack is
rather impressive, pastor bore, and gets
longer each week and that's what we
love. So, we'll get to it. If you don't
hear it this week, maybe next week or
the week after, but we will get to it.
Pastor Miranda, if you would open with
prayer for us, then we'll dive right
into our questions for today. Perfect.
Okay, let's pray. Dear heavenly father,
as we open up your word and try to
answer these questions from the Bible,
we pray that you may give us the wisdom
that we need in order not to twist your
words, but to present a clear thus
sayaith the Lord. In Jesus we pray.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Okay, let's uh take our first question,
which is a very good one. All questions
are good, by the way. Um, speaking of
circumcision, Pastor Boore stated that,
and now he's quoting, "It was an outward
visible manifestation of an internal
experience that God expected Israel to
have in their hearts." Mhm. Leviticus
12:3 states that a male child must be
circumcised on the eighth day. Since a
child who is only 8 days old has no
capacity to have such an internal
experience or to arrive at any kind of a
decision or conviction, how is the
concept outlined in the paragraph above
possible? Was it based on the internal
belief of the parents? I did not know
that circumcision when it was biblical
law required any kind of prior internal
belief or conviction. I thought it was
only a physical sign of the covenant
between God and Abraham or the
Israelites. I am not trying to be picky,
but I really need to understand this and
would appreciate some clarification on
the subject. And I appreciate your
sincerity in asking the question. Mhm.
Uh there is no um there is no law that
says that you cannot ask questions about
things that I've said which I've said a
lot of things and there's always
objections to what you say. Uh and this
is not objection. This is a sincere
question. So what can we say about it?
Well uh the reference that he cited is
not the very first time. I I found uh
the same set of circumstances enumerated
in Genesis chapter 17. Um this is my
covenant. Uh I'm starting at verse 10.
Which I which you shall keep between me
and you and your descendants after you.
Every male child among you shall be
circumcised circumcised and you shall be
circumcised in the flesh of your
foreskins and it shall be a sign of the
covenant between me and you. Now this
this statement is actually made to the
parents
uh uh telling them what to do. So it
ends with the fact it starts with the
fact that this is my covenant and ends
with the same word. So we know that it's
part of the anen of the covenant
relationship between God and his people.
Yeah. And uh you know the the question
is whether uh circumcision is in some
way related to baptism. Uh you know we
baptize people when they're adults.
Yeah. This is talking about circumcising
a child. But in both cases um it's a
sign of joining God's people making a
covenant with with God's people with the
church or in the Old Testament with
Israel. Uh so the parallel is not
precise but there is a text in
Colossians chapter 2 which relates
circumcision to baptism directly. Yes.
uh in Colossians chapter 2. Um
let's see here in verses um
I just had this verse 13 12 and 13. Yes.
Let's let's u if you would read
beginning with verse 11 uh Daniel
please. Okay. So in whom also you are
circumcised circumcised with the
circumcision made without hands in
putting off the body of the sins of the
flesh by the circumcision of Christ.
Mhm. Then 12. Uh-huh. Buried with him in
baptism, wherein also ye are risen with
him through the faith of the operation
of God who has raised him from death.
So, so, so you'll notice here that
circumcision is related to baptism. Uh,
the parallel is not precise. In both
cases, it's a sign that you're joining
God's people. Uh, but I believe that the
in the light of what you were saying,
the parents have a lot to do with uh the
Old Testament. They were supposed to
teach their children that circumcision
needed to be an experience of the heart.
Maybe we can read some New Testament
texts on the meaning of super uh
circumcision. It was not merely an
external sign in the flesh. It was much
deeper than that. Uh it's kind of like
the the removal of the foreskin
represented the removal of sin at the
moment of baptism. Uh maybe let's if we
can just distribute these texts. Romans
2 28 and 29. Uh maybe CA if you could
find that. uh Romans 2:20 and 29. And if
we could uh find uh Romans 4 11 and 12.
Okay. Uh Daniel, if you could look for
that, and then I'm going to read
Philippians chapter 3 and verse three.
Okay.
So, let's do Romans chapter 28 and 29
first. All right. 2:28.
For he is not a Jew who is one
outwardly, nor is circumcised that which
is outward in the flesh, but he is a Jew
who is one inwardly. And circumcision is
that of the heart, in the spirit, not of
the not in the letter, whose praise is
not from men, but from God. That's
powerful, isn't it? It is very clear. It
is. Now, let's read Romans 4:11 and 12.
Romans 4:11 and 12 says, uh, "And he
received the sign of circumcision, a
zeal of the righteousness of the faith,
which he had yet being uncircumcised,
that he might be the father of all men
that believe, though they be not
circumcised, that righteousness might be
imputed unto them also, and the father
of circumcision to them who are not of
the circumcision only, but who also walk
in the steps of that faith of our father
Abraham, which he had been yet
uncircumcised." Mhm. In Philippians
chapter 3,
uh this is the experience of the apostle
Paul. Chapter 3 and verse three, uh Paul
wrote, "For we are the circumcision
who worship God in the spirit, rejoice
in Christ Jesus, and have no confidence
in the flesh." So very clearly,
circumcision was a spiritual experience.
Yes. Furthermore, in the Old Testament,
God repeatedly says that he wants to
circumcise the hearts of the Israelites.
So, it's much deeper than just uh you
know, the physical act and uh you know,
thus becoming a member of the covenant
community, right? And I'd like to add
something to that and is that um it's
interesting to notice the context in
which the circumcision is given to
Abraham. We see that in in Genesis 17
that you quoted. But in chapter 16 of
Genesis, we see Abraham's sin with
Hagar. Um, but God had had already given
the the promise to Abraham and he had
already made a covenant, but Abraham
broke the covenant. And it's interesting
that God didn't ask him to pierce his
ear, but it was just with the very same
member that he sinned with, if you will.
So, uh, even though children were
supposed to be circumcised,
yet this was a reminder of them when
they were already conscious and grown up
of that salvation is not by works but by
faith. Right. Good point. Excellent
point. You know, two things I want to
say just before we leave this point.
Evidently, the Lord took this very
seriously. You recall the incident in
Exodus chapter 4. Abraham neglected to
circumcise his child and an angel stood
in the way to kill him. And of course
his wife uh wives always clean up after
their husbands, you know. Well, but the
wife was the one who didn't want the the
son circumcised. Precisely. Yeah. And so
she had to she had to go back and do
what she did and then she tossed it at
his foot and said, "You are a husband of
blood." Well, yeah. Yeah. You know what
it's interesting? Years ago, I was doing
a meeting in the Philippines. And in the
Philippines, they circumcised well into
the teens. Is that right? Yeah. They
have they have little shops with signs
out circumcision. you can take your 15,
16, 17 year old child to be circumcised.
And there was this child, he was about
14 years old, who wanted to be baptized
in the meeting, and he didn't show up
for the baptism. Uh, so I sent my Bible
worker over to uh the house to find out
why. Well, the mother didn't want him to
join the Adventist church. Oh. So, she
took him and had him circumcised the day
before. So, he was in no condition and
in no mindset to be dunked in the water
or anything else. He was in bed sort of
moaning and rolling. But they do that in
the Philippines till well well into your
late teens. Uh sometimes with
anesthetic, sometimes without. Yeah. It
almost sounds like what Simeon and Levi
did with the inhabitants of Sheckchham.
Yes.
Okay. Now, let's go to our next
question. Uh this question says the
following. I would be grateful to hear
your thoughts on Revelation 17:16.
Okay. Uh and I'm going to read it
because it's here on on the same sheet
where the question is. and the t horns
which thou sawest upon the beast, thee
shall hate the and shall make her
desolate, naked, and shall eat her
flesh, and burn her with fire.
Uh now I I might just mention that uh in
the book of Revelation, the harlot has
helpers.
The harlot is sitting on many waters.
Yes. Which means that the waters help
her. Also, she has her daughters because
she's the mother of harlots. So, her
daughters help her, the waters help her.
And then we also notice that she
fornicates with the kings of the earth,
which means that the the civil powers of
the world cooperate with her. So, this,
you know, this is a a trilogy that
actually helps the harlot. Yes. But
what's going to happen uh with this
union in Revelation 17:16,
we're told that this union is going to
fall apart. Fall apart and the daughters
are going to turn against her and the
kings, that's what this is mentioning,
waters are going to dry up on her. Yes.
So this is describing the climactic
moment when the supporters of the harlot
realize that they have been deceived by
the harlot and they withdraw their
support. Let's read Isaiah 47 verse9. Uh
if you could look that one up, Daniel
Isaiah 47:9 and CA Daniel 11:45.
Very interesting. Isaiah 47 is talking
about Babylon. Babylon. So you want to
read that? Yep. Isaiah 47:E9
the Bible says, "But these two things
shall come to thee in a moment in one
day, the laws of children and widowhood.
They shall come upon thee in their
perfection for the multitude of thy
sorceries and for the great abundance of
thine enchantments."
So what does it say there in Isaiah 47
and verse 9? It says uh these two things
shall come to you in a moment in one
day. The loss of children that's that
would be the daughters. Mhm. And
widowhood
the the that's her lovers, the kings.
The kings. Uh they shall come upon you
in their fullness. That's the turning
against her because of the multitude of
your sorceries. Of course, Revelation 18
speaks about the harlot being filled
with sorceries. uh for the great
abundance of your enchantments. And then
uh in the book of Revelation uh Daniel,
the harlot is referred to as the king of
the north. So what's going to happen
with the king of the north according to
Daniel 11:45?
And he shall plant the tents of his
palace between the sea and the glorious
holy mountain. Yet he shall come to his
end, and no one will help him. Mhm. So
that's talking about the final movements
where the papacy is about to to destroy
God's people and at that time he's going
to come to his end and there's not going
to be anyone to help him precisely. He's
going to lose his his uh helpers. We we
understand that that the harlot is in
control of all things because the fact
that she's riding upon uh all of these
things. So her support will be taken
away uh and she'll be accused of when
the people realize that they have been
deceived and and uh have been duped into
believing that which is not true. Yep.
Okay. So I hope that that's helpful. Uh
now we have this question. Does the
commandment say thou shalt not lie
or is it actually specific to not
claiming that others did something that
they didn't? Thou in other words such as
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor. So um does the
commandment forbid us only to lie is the
big question. You should not bear false
witness. Um Ellen White says this
no deviation from strict integrity can
meet God's approval. That approval that
was something that we had to memorize
when I was back in in in college. You
know the teacher was no deviation from
strict integrity. So that says no
movement away from the truth whether
it's and you know we can play games with
each other. I can say something and
leave out something that gives you a
totally false impression about what I
said. Well that's a deviation from
strict integrity. That's not going to
make saying that is uh that Sarah was
his sister. Yeah. And which is half
true. Uh same father different mother.
So he's half true but what he's trying
to say is save his life because he's not
trusting in the Lord. So, no deviation,
no moving away from the honest truth.
And then she has a lot of texts that
deal with our business dealings because
that's where we tend to want to cut
corners, you know. Um, you got to be
honest. Don't put your finger on a
scale, you know, do it fair and and
nothing else is going to be acceptable
to God. Yeah. A halftruth is a full lie.
Surely well said. Well, Ellen White
explains that commandment very clearly
in patriarchs and prophets where she
gives a list of of uh different ways in
which we can lie even with with our eyes
and with uh words or um with
exaggeration things. You know, I have
that quotation here from Patriarchs and
Prophets page 309.
Uh you know, it's interesting. uh when
we when we do this program, we don't
consult with one another before we do
the program. No. And yet so many times
CA has the same quotations that I do and
you just mentioned the same quotation
that I have in this sheet. So she says
false speaking in any manner every
attempt or purpose to deceive our
neighbor is here included. An intention
to deceive is what constitutes falsehood
by a glance of the eye. Yes. a motion of
the hand, an expression of the
countenance, a falsehood may be told as
effectually as by words. All intentional
overstatement,
exaggeration, every hint or insinuation
calculated to convey an erroneous or
exaggerated impression. Yes. Even the
statement of facts in such a manner as
to mislead is falsehood. Mhm. This
precept, she's talking about this partic
specific commandment. This precept
forbids every effort to injure our
neighbors reputation by misre
representation or evil surmising, by
slander or by tailbearing.
Even the intentional suppression of the
truth. Yes. By which injury may result
to others is a violation of the ninth
commandment. You know the psychologists
call it nonverbal communication. You can
you can communicate so much by just the
way you you turn your head, smiling at
the wrong time, frowning at the wrong
time, flip of the hand, so many of these
things. I've got a a a much shorter
quotation from Ellen White. The least
deviation from its requirements by
neglect or willful transgression is sin,
and every sin exposes the sinner to the
wrath of God. Wow. So you cannot you
cannot you must be honest in everything
you do and everything you say and even
your nonverbal communication has to be
in line with the truth. Well, it seems
to me that one of the most common sins
in God's people is lying and deception.
Yeah. No wonder that one of the
characteristics of the 144,000 is that
there is no guile in their mouths. Yeah.
So very interesting and important that
we are touching on this commandment.
Yeah. You know, um, Adventists many
times are notorious gossipers,
and that's one of the really bad sins
that are mentioned in scripture. Yeah.
Of course, all sins are bad, but some
sins uh are worse because of what the
effect they have on other people. Yeah.
The impact they have on other people.
That's why Dan is not part of the
144,000.
That's right. Yeah. Okay. Now, here's a
very interesting one. Okay. Um, any does
anybody want to say anything else about
that commandment? We're okay. All right.
I was listening to a well-known SDA
pastor give a sermon titled, "Babylon is
fallen. All God's Enemies will fail." He
talked about the spirit of Babylon and
how it can even be in us. Much of what
he said seemed accurate to me. However,
he said it was not one man. It was not
the Pope. Ellen White said it was a
symbol of the world at large. Um,
because I've only been learning and
studying for about three years now and
have much more to learn, my heart
genuinely loves God and I want to stay
in God's truths and not be led astray.
It is my understanding that when Babylon
has fallen has fallen, this is referring
to the papal system falling and all will
see they've been deceived by the Pope's
teachings. Am I correct? And if so, does
this verse apply which is to the law and
to the testimony? If they speak not
according to this word, it is because
there is no light in them. If so, am I
not the watch uh to watch and listen
anymore? So, basically uh this question
has to do with the identity of Babylon.
Is Babylon the papacy or is there a
broader uh meaning of the word Babylon?
Well, I have a comment on that.
Um,
when the second angel announces the fall
of Babylon, it is not referring
specifically to the papacy, to the
beast, right? Because the papacy was in
a fallen state many centuries ago, but
is most directly referring to the
daughters of of of the papal system
because they were uh they embraced the
doctrings of the papacy, right? Right?
And when they embrace them, they then
they achieve or they uh reach that
fallen condition. And in a broader
sense, it also includes every power or
earth that supports Babylon. Right.
Good, very good point. Oh, very good
point. In fact, in Revelation 16, uh we
verse 13, it corroborates that very
point that you just made. Uh Babylon is
composed of three parts. Three parts.
Mhm. It says there in verse 13 of
chapter 16 of Revelation, I saw three
unclean spirits like frogs coming out of
the mouth of the dragon, which Ellen
White identifies as the civil powers of
the world. It's Satan working through
the civil powers of the world. Yes. And
out of the mouth of the beast, which
represents the papacy. And out of the
mouth of the false prophet, which is the
same as the daughters of the harlot or
the beast that comes from the earth.
Very true. So, so Babylon has three
parts. And when Babylon falls, notice
verse 16, uh, verse 19, it clearly says
that Babylon has three parts because it
says, "Now the great city was divided
into three parts." Mhm. What is the
great city? Babylon. Babylon. So when
Babylon falls, uh, Babylon, uh, it means
that all of this union between the three
powers disintegrates. It falls apart.
Um, and I agree with you that in 1844
when the second angel's message,
actually leading up to 1844, the second
angel's message was proclaimed that
Babylon is fallen. Uh, it refers not to
the papacy because Ellen White says the
papacy had been fallen for centuries
before that. True. Uh, she says it must
apply to the Protestant churches. If I
can maybe read that statement, uh, great
controversy uh, 382 and 383. Uh she uh
wrote, "Babylon is said to be the mother
of harlots. By her daughters must be
symbolized churches that cling to her
doctrines and traditions and follow her
example of sacrificing the truth and the
approval of God in order to form an
unlawful alliance with the world." The
message of Revelation 14 announcing the
fall of Babylon must apply to religious
bodies that were once pure and have
become corrupt. Yes. M since this
message follows the warning of the
judgment, it must be given in the last
days. Therefore, it cannot refer to the
Roman church alone, for that church has
been in a fallen condition for many
centuries. Furthermore, in the 18th
chapter of the Revelation, the people of
God are called upon to come out of
Babylon. According to this scripture,
many of God's people must still be in
Babylon. And in what religious bodies
are the greater part of the followers of
Christ now to be found? without a doubt
in the various churches professing the
Protestant faith. Yeah, there is so much
that can be said and and and I was
thinking about the revelation 18 when
our forefathers thought that the door
was closed and they began to preach and
people began to join the church and I
said how does people join a church when
the door is closed? Obviously the door
is not shut you know so from the from
1844 to the close of time that call to
come out is in effect that angel is
still flying and that message is still
relevant till today and it means coming
out of the world coming out of
Protestantism coming out of the papal
system it applies to everyone who is not
gathered with the remnant of God. Amen.
Amen. Yeah. Okay. Any other um thoughts
about that question?
You know that that's why and and we come
back to this. That's why ministries like
Secrets Unsealed. That's why the Lord is
blessing this ministry and growing this
ministry. And of course, we we are just
on the verge of of some stupendous
announcements. God is calling. You know,
we have a question we'll not get to
about about um Saudi Arabia and these
other places. The only way we're going
to get in there is through television,
right? People can't go in there or
radio, you know, right? But God is God
is going to get his message in there
because he wants to do that. And so he
erects institutions like this one right
for that purpose to get the message
where man cannot go
the airwaves can go and the internet can
can go. So we need to use all of those
mechanisms to in fact you introduced the
next question. Ah here it is
um it's referring to Matthew 24:14
gospel of the kingdom will preach to all
the world as a witness to all nations
then the end will come. According to
this verse, how would Jesus come back
soon if the people in countries like
Saudi Arabia, China, North Korea, etc.
haven't been reached mainly because of
their government preventing the gospel
from reaching the people. And my answer
is always, if Jonah in a three-day
evangelistic crusade through the power
of the Holy Spirit was able to win
120,000 souls, I don't think that God
God's hand is short to be able to finish
the work. Well said. Amen. But but I
agree with you 100%. and that is that
media is going to be tremendously
instrumental in finishing the work.
Media to my mind was invented for the
promagation of the gospel. Now the
problem is anytime you leave anything
lying around on the ground, Satan picks
it up and runs on it. So he's got uh a
little head start on us in using media.
But we are reclaiming media to a great
extent. And everywhere Satan is God's
people are right there also with a
powerful message to counteract uh what
Satan is doing. and and media is going
to play a great great great part in the
finishing of the work. I agree 100%.
Amen. And you know, Secrets Unsealed is
an evidence of that. It's a living
evidence that media uh does reach people
because you don't even have to knock on
the door. Precisely. You know, you can
get into people's houses
through without going through the door.
Amen. Amen. So um so anyway, God has a
million ways um or a thousand ways
according to the spirit of prophecy to
do things that we know nothing about.
And we know that the gospel will go and
it will be fast. Final movements are
rapid ones according to the spirit of
prophecy. Well, I guess we need to bring
this to a close. CA, praise the Lord.
You know, you talk about the moves being
fast and I'm I'm very aware of the time.
Um, we had a fellow he who who preached
and uh quit preaching because he just
didn't feel a call anymore. But he found
out about the Sabbath. He went back to
his church. The first Sunday he was
there. He was the only one in the
building. By the next weekend, the
church was full. The whole church joined
the Lordise. Join joined the and started
keeping the Sabbath. So, the movies are
going to be wrapped once. Thank you so
much for joining us. Thank you for your
questions. Keep them coming. We will
keep answering them by the grace of God.
We'll see you again next time.
[Music]